HE'S A GUY THE FLYERS WILL HAVE
TO KEEP ANPART OF
THE BOARD.
FLYERSOF CHANCNCWHO IN THE OPPO
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU COMES
YORK PINCHES, BUT ABLE TO GET
SHOCKS END.
ATKINSON M M THEMERKLEY FIGHTIN.
FLYERS CAN GET THEIR HERTL, STO
AND ULTIMATELY IT WAS ATKINSONA
MEGNA'S SHOT,
.
>> Keith: FANS HAVING AESTOURS.
OFF THE BENCH.
HITS CATES, OUT IN FRONT,
MACEWEN HITS IT
JONES.
BRAUN IS TIRED.
THIS PUCK PLAYED THEESS
GAME.
THE
JUSTIN BRAUNTIP, AS D ATTEMPT ON
TO CAM RIGHT THERE, AS ATKINSON
WILL GET IT OES GET A STICK
ON IT.
WE JUST HAVE TO SEE IF THE
SAN JOSE ZONE.
MEIER BACKHANDS  GET THE PUCK
TO
GAME FOR B B YEAH, TALK ABOUT
SAVE, THIS SAVE BY ADIN HILL
THAT SHOT BY NICK MERKLEY, AND
THAT PUCK RIGHT THERE,
WEATHERBY WITH AS
BURNS.
BURNS CHECKED BY ATKINSON.
BACKHANDER.
SAVE MADE BY STILL GETS A
BACKHANDER, AND D TOP UNIT OUT
THERE.
TURNOVER.
CATES'S SHOT GOES WIDE, AND
HILLLLTHE ON
GOAL, HE SCORES!
TOMAS HERTL, ALL THREE GOALS
FOR